ha ha ha ha what did I tell you come on
what you grab that microphone right
there oh yeah have a seat have a seat
with us and your and your Golden Globe
you're not getting too old to win a
Golden Globe I told you on the car you
did you said I'd win it yes but I
thought you were paid to say that it's
working is it yeah you apologize to
everyone why because you know they're
those guys are going through agony you
know they're sitting there thinking is
it gonna be me
it's probably gonna be Brian Cox is it
gonna be me you know and show you you
owe them an apology for going through
that it's hell yeah but it's one hell of
a party tonight isn't always a hell of a
party tonight it's a great party that's
that's the great thing about it it's
it's a really good party and then you
turn around the show wins also yeah and
so it has been a big night your little
show I know it has and it's a great show
I'm gonna
it's getting the credit it Julie
deserves I mean in terms of Jesse
because it's all comes back to Jesse
or is it did just people really love
rich people having problems they do you
know and they don't understand why they
love rich people right they actually go
they're embarrassed about it ok tell me
true is can I say you could say anything
you are so I'm I'm at a I'm enemy2
evening uh-huh arranged by Rosanna
Arquette and so I go on to this evening
and there's Ronan Farrow doing his stuff
yep and being really incredible and an
incredible book and I'm very touched by
his work and yeah Ronan's done is
astonishing and he actually helped a
friend of mine come free and admit to
what had happened to her so I was very
grateful to him so I'm there and then
just as I'm only believing I'm
surrounded by all these women and not
all of them but one or two came up to me
and said could you tell me to [ __ ] off
is that really appropriate and a me-too
evening that I a white dinosaur tells
you to
I said where the [ __ ] is your head man
but it has become well that's the show
that is that's the show and everybody
loves it that's what the show does you
know it's effective people in that way
what kind of pressure does it put on you
guys now because now everybody's coming
you know some of us who watched it from
the beginning it's the pressure on the
writers but they'll do they'll come up
with stuff because they're such a great
bunch there's such a phenomenal bunch of
people I also want to know do you
renegotiate tomorrow or do you give them
a like a week before you renegotiate in
probably about four hours you're like
let's redo this deal because guess who
you're not doing the show without this
man right here he ain't dying you tried
to kill him off but he ain't die
congratulations your lovely wife does
she stay out a Mele of you know I had to
go they just took me and owned me for
this last run so go enjoy this night and
congratulations thank you thank and I
expect you to take me everywhere you go
from now and I'm your good luck charm
[Music]